from john glenn to neil armstrong
america's most famous
astronauts have been men but one woman
is changing that
peggy whitson has spent more time in
space than any other nasa astronaut
and now in retirement she's going back
mark strassman spoke with her about
launching into a new frontier
commercial space flight in peggy
whitson's dreams
she floats her dream is always about
space
and it's about to come true again you
know of course i
dreamed of wanting to go but you never
know exactly how long that process is
going to take and so you know
luckily i'm not dead and i'm going back
and welcome
on board the international space station
whitson has spent more time in space
than any american in history 665 days
almost two years in 2008 she became the
space station's
first female commander whitson has also
made
10 spacewalks no other american has more
sometime late next year she'll head back
up but for the first time
flying private for a company called
axiom space
what's left for you to do up there maybe
there's just
the the desire to see the earth again to
have that perspective
have you missed that view from 250 miles
up
oh absolutely axiom's business is space
mission management its first flight to
the iss
called ax1 will fly four civilians on a
spacex crew dragon
next january now 61 whitson will command
ax2 her pilot john shafner an
entrepreneur
race car driver and veteran civilian
pilot two other crew members have yet to
be named
how is the challenge different for a
commander when the crew
is all amateur astronauts you know you
can teach people what they
need to know to be safe if there were an
emergency
would the crew be comfortable in
responding
i will make sure that you get enough
training to be that way
trust me
we're in a new frontier of commercial
space flight with players like spacex
blue origin virgin galactic and axiom
more civilians will head to space like
whitson
final hugs as she departs the space
station who thought she was earthbound
after retiring from nasa in 2018.
will this be your last time no i hope
not
realizing a dream often means reaching
for the stars
peggy whitson is proof of that for cbs
this morning
mark strassman atlanta go peggy whitson
wow
hey bravo peggy whitson listen if you're
a civilian
crew crew person wouldn't you feel good
knowing that peggy whitson is
on board with you absolutely can you
imagine can you imagine the songs you
could write the music you could write if
you were just floating around
coming in space john padis the way your
brain works
yeah i feel like one day that's going to
happen i'm going to call it out now i'm
going to claim that i'm playing space
yeah you want to go great i want to go
with peggy whitson
that's exactly you know but we can say
on this date you're calling out you're
going to space
that's right all right just come on
carefully your piano doesn't end up like
that be careful
careful right you don't want that